okay so back to
the uh my thoughts on the
hongbu dojo and ikigai
certification what bothers me
is you finally
well perhaps other people have not
thought of it
but i found finally woke up to
martial arts in the
the world has always been for people who
are more well-off
even even in japan they the rich
people would do these martial arts
and the poor people wouldn't and we use
what wooden
cans and joes the samurais would have
the real swords rather than go into
history i'd like to still talk about
um the business side
it saddens me to think that in the early
days
it must have been quite slow than the
money coming in
all the teachers japanese teachers would
go out around the world
start their class and it must have been
hard at first
then over the years it become more
popular
steven seagal put it on the map aikido i
believe anyhow
and the club classes were really large
regular
and everybody's paying a little bit into
their club and
only thinking about the art they love
how much they get out of it
and the pure pleasure that doesn't come
into
money when it gets to
taking the showdown test that first down
black belt
for for me i never really well would
because
what's a hundred pound two hundred pound
i was in business
quite well off but what about
these very poor countries you're even
now
five hundred dollars for
fourth down fifth down
a thousand perhaps for a seventh then
the the prices vary from year to year
but how to someone who's
almost working for two weeks or
a whole month's wages just to get a
piece of paper
that they've earned their teacher has
said that they're good enough
and someone at the other end who doesn't
even know them signs the piece of paper
it's a great honor to receive this piece
of paper and i've received many
and i hang them on the wall some people
just leave them
in the box that they've turned in
knowing that they've earned that grade
and they're worthy of it and they
hopefully will want to strive
to go further
whether they're worth it or not in my
opinion
i'll go into in other films
because nowadays i'm seeing the ranks
going much higher at much earlier age
and so much of it is choreographed
set up they don't know it because that's
the way they were taught from the day
the student first arrived in the dojo
they were told what to do
talking sheep and the head of the herd
told them exactly what to do how they
should do it
but the buzz aikido gives us we have
become blind
to the reality of what we are supposed
to be getting out of it
the thing is we do get so much out of
aikido
it touches strings of our heart and our
soul
that cannot perhaps be found in other
arts it's a very very deep understanding
art and out of all the things i've done
in life
i'm still searching because i'm getting
so much pleasure out of it
but i also now think well
it's a money-making machine and that's
a little sad but as long as it doesn't
affect us we can keep
searching for our like you know the
hundreds and
thousands and i mean hundreds and
thousands
of people who have made their black
belts at all different levels
all this money train is going back to
the hombu dojo
to support the factory you may not
like to think of it as a factory but it
has several floors
where classes are being taught
throughout the day
people will go there because they want
everybody wants to go to mecca at some
time in their life
the same as i wanted to go to iwama
to me that was mecca a lot of people
went to walmart didn't like it was too
hard
whether you do any style of aikido
it's enjoyable they're all hard
because they're all demanding of fitness
from the body
and if the body has to work really hard
then
you're going to get bruises you're going
to get damaged
very occasionally you get the breakage
not so often i'm really pleased to say
but you will get the breakages
so we're not doing it for the money
reason
we're doing it for personal satisfaction
did kishimura do it for
upholding his father's aigido
giving it to the world there's no sense
he wanted to
he wanted the people of japan to share
his
art to start to heal
after the war to heal the nation
let's heal it by giving love to each
other
and caring for each other this was
the message he wanted
did kishimura also on this or was he
thinking
this is a very good business model and
if it's thought out correctly
with his academic background
he could make it into a large operation
throughout the world
and he certainly did and
and that is what we've
been doing in the early days
i'd done ten years as i've already said
it was mixed i think looking back on it
it was a mixture of it
the women aikido and the hong kong
because it was
fast flowing but very
powerful and strong techniques
they felt like they were working we only
used to do
the seven cancer brewery we then
learned the 31 and some of the senior
black belts in the club in london they
made up cumin hatches from the sword
work
they made their own because we didn't
have such set pieces
and they were really nice to watch but
until we were first q
we were not even allowed to pick up a
ken swing again
it was classed as a high level
understanding
now we teach the people from the day
they walk in the dojo
about ken and joe so there is
advancement
and in the next films i hope to talk
about
the pluses and as i've seen the minuses
of weapons and tits
thank you for your time please subscribe
to my channel
if you're enjoying them and any comments
at any time
are helpful